it's great to welcome to the program
today david shimer who's a fellow at
yale university and also
author of the book rigged america russia
and 100 years of covert
electoral interference uh david the
title already
tells us a lot about uh my first
question but
um in the in the discussion about
alleged russian interference in the 2016
election
and planned interference in 2020 there's
this bigger discussion of
how long has transnational election
interference been going on so so maybe
let's start there where
how long has it been going on sure so
what i do in my book is i restore
history to the subject of covert
electoral interference because
a myth that is prevalent in our
discourse today
is that russian interference in the 2016
election
um was somehow new or novel or
unprecedented
and and that's dangerous because if
something's treated as unprecedented
then it's treated as something that
there's no history behind and it's very
easy to manipulate how people perceive
it and whether people even believe it
happened
and what i do in this book is show that
in fact for the last century beginning
in 1919
the soviet union for a period the united
states and then now putin's russia have
been interfering in elections all over
the world i show
where i show why i show how they have
used their intelligence services
to direct and disrupt open elections
and i then use that history to shine new
light on what actually happened in 2016
how we can understand what putin
achieved and what we should be doing now
to defend our elections both before
november
and and thereafter so there's like five
different
branches that we could explore i'll just
pick
one to start with what would be since
1919
the most successful examples of that
interference
sure so there's one case that that it
was actually what sparked my interest in
this whole subject
which was in 1972 there was a vote of no
confidence in the
chancellor of west germany willie brandt
and this and this vote of no confidence
came
at a pivotal moment in the history of
the cold war willie brandt had been
executing a foreign policy of us politic
he had been reestablishing relations
with the soviet union with the eastern
bloc
a real pivotal cold war figure which um
as a result of his groundbreaking
policies sparked um
dissent within his parliamentary
coalition and there was a vote to remove
him from office as chancellor
that vote failed by two votes just two
after which he was able to ratify the
treaties he'd been pursuing
and and and really pursue um to
completion
um or as he saw his foreign policy and
what i reveal in the book
is that there was a covert operation
executed by east german intelligence
ordered by moscow
to purchase those two votes and i
interviewed one of the intelligence
officers
who participated in that operation he
now lives just outside of berlin i spent
about half a day with him
i went through a bunch of different
archives and recreated this story
and it's a story of targeting two
vulnerable lawmakers
who were very corruptible because of
their womanizing their debts um their
alcoholism
turning them drawing them in slowly and
then paying them each 50
000 deutsche marks in exchange for their
extensions and then covering it up
and it took decades for this operation
to come out um and
had the east german intelligence um
agency not interfered in this vote
the outcome would have been different
brant would have fallen from power and
the trajectory of the cold war would
have changed
um and it did not as a direct result of
covert interference
just briefly do you know offhand how
much 50 000 deutsche marks then is
roughly
like how many dollars today would we be
thinking about like a little less than a
hundred thousand dollars
okay so it's not a crazy amount no
certainly given the
the the way in which it redirected the
the trajectory of things at the time
um now as a sort of disclaimer moment
you we are not arguing here that
russia is the only country that does
this we are just we happen to be talking
about russia but that's a common defense
that
number one other countries also do this
and number two
the u.s also does this elsewhere you're
not denying either of those assertions
no i'm denying i'm denying neither of
those assertions but i do make the
argument in my book
that the story of covert electoral
interference is primarily to this point
this may change now moving forward but
to this point has primarily been a story
of moscow and washington so between 1919
and 1947
the soviet union was interfering in
elections all over the world with brief
interruptions and very intensely
between 45 and 47 across eastern europe
between 1948 and 1991
the cia and the kgb were going
toe-to-toe in elections all over the
world
in order to either seek to defeat um or
advance
leftist candidates and since 1991
vladimir putin's regime has rediscovered
and enhanced the weapon of covert
electoral interference using the
internet
he is once again targeting elections all
over the world in order to support
authoritarian minded and divisive
candidates um
and now one of the countries under
attack in a real meaningful way is
america itself
so this is a very old story and there
are many lessons to draw from that story
as we seek to understand our present
moment
it is not accurate to say that it is
just russia that has been executing
these sorts of operations but we also
shouldn't minimize the role of moscow in
this history because moscow really has
been the pioneer
um beginning with vladimir lenin in 1919
to the regime vladimir putin today
so what was done in 2016.
and i think maybe what would be useful
would be to contextualize it in you know
when you have an election that
ultimately comes down to about 75 000
votes in three states and otherwise
would have would have been a hillary
clinton
win we have to balance
what russia did with james comey
opting to do a second presser about
hillary clinton's emails
with targeted social media campaigns
hillary clinton
not going to wisconsin right like we can
when it's so close
it's hard to say one thing was the
difference maker but that still means we
should explore
what exactly did russia do exactly and i
think it's a real
trap to fall into the question of
effectiveness when it comes to
operations to manipulate people
because there are two ways to manipulate
an election to alter actual ballots and
to manipulate minds public opinion
and as i said i've scoured this history
i interviewed more than 130 people eight
former cia
directors gone through archives across
six countries and what comes out of that
history
is that for operations to manipulate
people there's
never a clear answer as to how many
people were manipulated or how many
people's minds were changed it's about
making informed analytical judgments and
then
orienting future policy based on those
judgments it's the first point the
second point as to what russia did
is russia did three things the first is
russia systemically manipulated social
media platforms with with propaganda
in spreading propaganda that advanced
its two objectives to sow discord and
division
um and to advantage one candidate over
another which by the way is nothing new
i spent about half a day with the former
kgb general and they tried to do both of
those things
in many u.s elections during the cold
war they just didn't have social media
to do it
the the second thing that russia did was
hack and release sensitive emails that
were damaging to
hillary clinton's candidacy and the
third thing that russia did
was systemically target our voting
systems which was actually what
captivated the obama administration in
the summer and fall
because russian military intelligence
was scanning probing and penetrating
our election infrastructure to the point
where according to folks like john
brennan
um russia had the ability to alter the
vote tallies and voter data of u.s
citizens on election day itself
so there's people who will look at that
and they'll say you know that's a lot of
work
for ultimately getting donald trump
elected
um to the extent that it helped and in
the end
donald trump really hasn't done that
much that seems great for russia and
you'll have people provide lists on both
sides here's things that trump did that
seem
good for russia here's things trump did
that seem not so good
for me it's never really been about that
it's been about
listen the the u.s now is a laughing
stock in a way that it was not prior to
2016.
the u.s is not in conversations about
climate change because trump says
it's a hoax created by the chinese the
u.s is increasingly i mean on
coronavirus we're not leading
for me it's not about getting specific
concessions
it's about questioning how stable is the
us
and how how clearly are people thinking
and and it's a bigger picture thing
where
it's sort of the downfall
of american democracy broadly more than
about
trump doing things for putin is that the
right lens or is it a different lens we
should be thinking of
no you're spot on i think a real
misconception is that
putin got help to get trump elected so
therefore trump is going to
cede ukraine to russia or something like
that and and that kind of transactional
view of why trump is a value to putin
and that really misunderstands putin's
foreign policy and his and his and his
his strategy really which is in america
to degrade disrupt and discredit
american democracy to corrupt american
democracy in itself so when trump causes
chaos
when trump sews discord when trump
erodes democratic norms
that is the dream of russia the the that
matters so much more than what might be
happening
regarding a specific foreign policy
decision because what vladimir putin
wants
is for american democracy to erode for
him to therefore be able to say to his
own
people see democracy doesn't work um the
story of american democracy was a myth
and you shouldn't want that
it opens up new opportunities for
influence for him because as america
retreats as a leader abroad
that means that states will therefore be
more
susceptible to russian influence
and it also makes it so that america is
so divided at home
is so disrupted at home that america
can't push back against russia abroad
and can't engage with russia
in a meaningful way abroad so trump
could do nothing
transactionally that helps russia and
yet the trump presidency can be of
enormous value
to putin and that is the best way to
understand what trump's presidency has
thus far been for example
what we see happening in portland right
now you know it's having
soldiers or dhs officials who don't have
marks on their uniforms
it's reminiscent of what putin did in
ukraine with his soldiers being unmarked
and it also shows that america and
russia
you know it enables this what about this
sort of argument that that america
should be seeking to rebut
because there is no equivalency or
should not be between russian and
american behavior domestically
when it comes to the other superpower of
china
um one of the allegations that has been
made
is that donald trump specifically asked
the chinese president
for help when it comes to farmers the
idea being
china buys stuff from american farmers
this helped trump helps trump with the
farmers that helps him get reelected in
2020. that's like a really specific ask
more broadly there's this interview from
last year where trump was interviewed by
george stephanopoulos and stephanopoulos
said
if russia or china came to you with
information that was useful to you
would you call the fbi would you accept
it and trump said well yeah i would look
at it first and then you know maybe i
tell the fbi maybe i wouldn't
talk a little bit about either
abstractly or concretely
the role of china in the 2020 election
so i think that's a really open and
interesting question because 2016 was a
turning point in this history in a
couple of ways one of which was
it was the first time the issue of
covert electoral interference was really
broadcast to the world
it exited the shadows and it showed
china iran north korea
whomever you can really disrupt american
democracy with not that much money
um and with relatively simple ideas
because of how exposed our country is
so i think a question on my mind is
whether china seeks to
imitate and further the russian model or
whether this will continue to be a
russian tradition i don't know the
answer to that i think we will know the
answer in the coming months
but i think something that we should be
clear-eyed about is that to this point
this has been much more a russian story
than a chinese story
so folks who say china will break new
ground here
north korea or iran and it's as if
everyone's operating from the same
starting point that's just not
true you know vladimir putin worked for
the kgb for 15 years he was a part of an
agency that was interfering in elections
all over the world there's a history
here
there's a reason why russia is at the
forefront here and i think we should
keep that in mind and a brief point on
trump
i also think americans really need to
keep in mind that regardless of what he
says this is not a political
issue if you believe in this threat that
doesn't make you you know a democrat
the the soviets targeted ronald reagan
during the cold war a republican
they targeted richard nixon a republican
to destroy their campaigns
now they just so happen to be helping a
republican but the point isn't to help a
republican the point is to further the
interests of the russian state
which is to degrade corrupt and tear
down american democracy
and that is not in alignment with the
interests of any american citizen
regardless of political party
so to touch on 2020 and russia then
if you look at the polls now they
certainly don't look good
for donald trump but as i've been
telling my audience
you have to assume nothing you have to
vote as if your vote is the deciding
vote in your state that's really the
only the only intelligent way forward
but does does russia's ability to meddle
become diminished if indeed the election
is not close
or do their priorities change or how
does that affect things
so their priorities change because
another myth here is that russian
interference is just about getting
donald trump elected
again not true russia's operations
interfere in the 2016 election
started in 2014 before trump even
announced his candidacy
and as i reveal in my book based on my
interviews with john brennan and jim
clapper
russia had plans to continue interfering
in our politics to undermine hillary
clinton had she won the election and
they were basically
starting that operation before trump
even won which surprised
putin so as we await election day now
it's important to keep in mind that the
foremost russian objective again
is to undermine our democracy to sow
doubt about the functioning of our
democracy and yes
trump might be losing but new
opportunities emerge such as if donald
trump is alleging that the election will
be rigged
it is in russia's interest for americans
to believe their election is rigged
because that makes americans no longer
believe in their democracy so russia
could and this is hypothetical
but russia did have this capability four
years ago you know scramble voter
registration databases caused chaos at
polling places
anonymously to therefore provide fodder
to those who would allege
that the election was rigged for the
democratic side
so therefore after the election half the
country might not actually believe in
the outcome of the election
which would only so further division and
further discredit american democracy in
the eyes of the world as well as its own
people so
there are many ways to achieve the
russian objective
donald trump is a means to an end of
that objective of undermining american
democracy but he's not the end in itself
and americans should keep that in mind
because this threat will not disappear
regardless of whether donald trump loses
because this is a long-running russian
mission
the kgb has targeted american elections
for decades russia
has been interfering in our politics
since before trump came on the scene and
that story will continue
in 2021 and beyond the book is
rigged america russia and 100 years of
covert electoral interference we've been
speaking with the books author david
shimer a fellow at yale university
i so appreciate your time today thank
you very much